you made it you made it you made it oh
yeah you made it
it you made it weird with
petees what's happening weirdos this is
uh this is an exciting week for old py
not only is Jonathan Scott who you may
know from Property Brothers like the big
home renovation TV show in in recorded
history is on the show also this is one
of those did we just become Best Friends
episodes which I love he's so engaging
he's so interesting he's so funny he's
so open I loved it you're going to love
it thanks for being here but it's a big
week Al also because my Netflix special
dropped uh yesterday so it's on Netflix
I am not for everyone it's on Netflix
right now my first Netflix special I'm
very very excited please please please
please check it out I hope you like it I
worked really hard on it I'm proud of it
and I think far and away it's my best
special yet so please check that out and
if you'd like to see me on the road I'm
doing a new hour not the hour from I am
not for everyone that is retired I'm
doing a new hour I'll be in Bloomington
Indiana this weekend and then after that
is Chicago and Washington DC all the
dates will be added at Pete holes.com
only a couple things to uh plug up top a
lot of a lot of comments on my
hair it's true in the Netflix special uh
looking good hair and uh I got to tell
you like I'm not even reading the ad yet
modern mammals is a game changer when it
comes to my hair routine it used to be
if I wanted my hair to look good for
something I would not wash it for at
least 2 days maybe more 3 four days and
then at one point my hairdresser and
friend cat was like your hair is gross
it looks good but it's gross you need to
clean it so I was hoping that there
would be a non shampoo shampoo solution
that would clean your hair but not make
it look like a bail of hay that just
came out of the dryer unruly all over
the place and brittle and that's exactly
what modern mammals is no lie no joke I
found it on Instagram I tried it once I
reached out to them I was like we got to
partner up this stuff is a game changer
it's a non shampoo shampoo and over
40,000 guys have switched to this
instead of traditional shampoo you got
to see the reviews for this product
they're insane guys don't get this
excited about anything it blows my mind
once you use it like me you're hooked
hooked for life there's no other shampoo
you can't go back and it's a small punk
rock Grassroots company these guys were
just fed up with shampoo frying their
hair and set out to create something
actually new to help men with their hair
to look good specifically for guys they
have bars for the no plastic and the no
fragrance version and they also have
bottles for the more traditional shampoo
style it's like a magic gray mud that
you run into your hair rinse it out
gives you a great feeling look gives you
that wave it gives you that body it
doesn't dry it out it makes your hair
clean but look like you didn't wash it I
mean that's a miracle that's a straight
up miracle I also love the fragrance I
love that it makes my hair every single
time perfect 6 seconds day perfect hair
I used it before my special I use it
before everything I'm going to do for
the rest of my for the remainder of my
days to get JRR token about it modern
mammals. comom weird where you can get a
special combo and try both products the
bar and the bottle for 44 bucks that's
modern mammals. weird support your hair
get that wave support the show really
love them speaking of pizs that I'm
super excited about first person is an
absolute Mind Body game Cher they are
helping my life they're helping Val's
Life by helping us naturally produce
more oxytocin the the feel-good hormone
and dopamine which is a motivating
feel-good hormone incredible incredible
stuff and what is it when I have to
explain first person to somebody in 5
seconds I go it's mushrooms it's
mushrooms that are specifically targeted
to dial into your body to boost that
good mood feeling energy mood sleep
first person has got you covered golden
hour is the one I started with helps me
tune into a sense of Joy connection and
relax relaxed presence I love taking it
in conjunction with Sunbeam which
maximizes productivity and creative
activities by tuning in to be an
inspired focused mindset by helping
boost your the body's natural production
boost that of dopamine so you're spiking
your dopamine your peaking your oxytocin
it's incredible to find this natural
hack this bioh hack it is incredible and
Moonlight I take every night to help me
stay in sleep uh deep restorative sleep
by helping uh the Gaba neurotransmitter
to relax the central nervous system
preparing the brain for body and sleep
they're meant to be stacked and I stack
them take them together get that
motivating feeling and that well-being
feeling it's 100% grain-free organic
mushrooms they're also in really cool
containers and they look really cool as
well and they're highly curated blend of
neuticals first person as a game changer
start improving your brain health and
cognition with first person get 20% off
your first order by going to get
firstperson decom and use promo code
weird support your mind support the show
first person there's no going back it's
amazing these statements I have to say
they have not been evaluated by the Food
and Drug Administration these products
are not intended to diagnose treat cure
or prevent any disease get into it get
firstperson decom and use promo code
weird all all right everybody enjoy
Jonathan Scott it's awesome so glad
you're here please check out the special
on Netflix all right that's it get into
it make sure it's on check che check oh
this make sure this is on sure it's
actually on I'm the worst so the one
thing they have with me on set is um
constantly my phone will ring and and
blow a take constantly like literally
every day why turn it off there I don't
know why I can't figure it out
I leave my fly down half of my show has
been shot with my fly hanging open and I
and they're like why don't you remember
I'm like I have this weird thing when I
go to the bathroom you and you touch
your junkie Parts yeah yeah yeah I don't
like to touch anything else until I wash
my hands so I don't do my fly until I
wash my hands wait you want your fly to
be clear of balls I don't know why do
fly is a ball safe area I would think so
you can touch balls to fly and also my
balls are are also clean but yeah money
is dirty yeah it is how do you do you
wash your hands after you touch money
I've actually been known to pick my
teeth with bills so and it makes
everyone vomit around me but I'm like
you floss with a crisp 50 I'm not going
to lie in my mind I justify it that the
higher the bill the fewer people have
touched it and so but yeah I've had like
I don't know how many yeah the one is
the TR do not put a one anywhere near
your mouth can you say
uh the one is you know it's just been
all over yeah one one is it's in vending
machines although that's kind of its Car
Wash gets pressed yeah I guess it's
pressed unlike your shirt but uh can you
tell us the first time I've wor
literally almost smell the cellophane
package that you took out and yeah but I
put it on for you I appreciate it it's
hard to be talking to the sexiest man I
think it's the sexiest man alive the
sexiest man alive not quite it's uh
number one sexiest one one people's one
of 50 sexiest men alive 50 though that's
they they knew what they were doing they
kept that number that's annoying though
is it was a list of 50 yet there were 51
people in the list because they they
qualify Drew and me as one human between
the two of us I think that's just honest
I I mean that's what we're all doing hey
people would gift at Christmas they
would just give us one gift and expect
that we're going to share so I get
Tuesdays and Thursdays and he gets the
other days I don't know how was supposed
to work that is uh you know we've had
I'm friends with the scar brothers and
Twins and they have some twin laments
and they're all super legitimate you
know what I mean oh yeah there's there's
all the stuff that you typically would
like they joke about the people say to
twins people say to twins all the time
and like we're like social experiments
something if you get hit does he feel so
the way the way to kill that
conversation wait and no no and no I
just hate it for on your behalf and
you're tall so people are going you know
all those thingsa but the the greatest
way to kill that whole twin stick that
people always say is yeah you just go
yeah it's crazy when I orgasm he feels
it and then there's a really awkward
silence and then people move on would
all be trying to be twins get your mind
out of the gutter over there I Katie's
loving the the twines material old
twines classic Katy material
over um yeah that must be annoying but
it's also like you know what it is is
when you see a very very very like I was
at the airport and I saw a very very
tall person I mean he had to be like 9t
like for real like circus level and
we're so fascinated we're also
fascinated with little people I'm not
trying to be funny I'm just saying it's
interesting it's different twins are the
only outlying group that for some reason
and redheads it's completely okay to
just come up and be like and stare you
have red hair are you a leprechaun or
twins you can be like where is the end
of the rainbow yeah exactly like yeah
yeah so what I've deduced is that people
generally are dumb especially when
they're traveling airports are the worst
people they check their brains with
their luggage and they granted though I
think the first time we met I walked up
and I did say something tall like I
guess we should talk to each other
because we're the yeah and I at the Biga
thing yeah and then you like shot a look
at me like oh this [__] guy this I
did not no you didn't i' be you're
literally the friendliest guy in the
world I know but so are you have you
ever look I'm not even trying to put you
on the spot but sometimes people go like
yeah I came up to you and and and I must
have been like exhausted or sick or
something and I was just sort of like
hello you know what I
mean the thing is these days people will
go Direct on on social media and then
they'll just troll you this person's
horrible yeah so I have a thing where if
I'm talking to somebody I like I don't
like it when somebody obnoxious comes
over and interrupts because they want to
take a picture they want to I'm in the
middle of a conversation with somebody
especially if you're sitting like in a
restaurant in an intimate situation I
don't like when people just bombard your
table restaurant all the time yeah
constant but usually just like the
petting kind of stuff heavy P heavy
heavy pet it's hard to do light petting
light petting leads to heavy unless it's
linen service on the tables if there's
like linen service it's a lot easier so
well that's that's just begging for
petting uh Lin you asked for it
restaurants those are bed sheets for a
table exactly that's what linen service
is duh duh but don't blacklight those
Linens anyway so no I had one I was I
was CH chatting with this lady and she
was like the sweetest woman she must
have been in her early 90s something
like that and she saw me at the airport
and she was really kind and said she
likes the show I have the best fans in
the world they're very sweet and this
guy literally all but shoves her out of
the way and says hey hey whoa you're
you're you're the guy on the show I I
got to take a picture and I said to him
like oh I'm just in the middle of
conversation I'll I'll I'll be a few
minutes yeah I could tell he was Furious
absolutely livid and then immediately I
saw when I ported my flight all of a
sudden I was getting these notifications
and this guy was on there saying I'm the
biggest [__] in the world and bl I'm
like no my friend yeah you are but the
problem is other fans that read that
then they're like oh wow Jonathan must
have been really rude I'm like well
that's his side of the story that's why
I don't take for a grain of salt any of
the stories I see about people out there
because what you're human you're allowed
to be sick you're allowed to have a bad
day you're allowed to not be invaded I
just had a dream where I screamed at
someone I'm not allowed to be in a bad
mood that was my
dream when you're Furious in your dream
about I was yelling at my brother cuz I
was in a bad mood and and I have this
belief not to get too deep right away
but I have this belief that if I'm angry
I must be like the the part of my dad
that like would frighten me as a child
or whatever he wasn't like a monster or
anything but like that sort of is scary
to a kid so I have this weird
relationship with anger and being like
aggressive so when I get that way I
think that the dream meant like what
what is the last time that you actually
in real life not in dream life but in
real life got mad at
something yeah it it was my I got mad at
my dad we had a little we had a little
conversation which is funny CU there it
is the thing that I I'm at odds with my
anger and I'm talking to that thing and
we're looking for it but is we never
like name call and stuff we were just
watching a short film that my friend
made and and they were like [__] you you
[__] child and like having fights
like that I've never in my life had a
fight like that never in my life I've
never called my dad a name I've never
called a girlfriend a name I'm not
trying to Virtue signal some people can
like I have to imagine like this sounds
weird but like other cultures like I'm
just very tight and Lithuanian and like
you'll I don't I don't even know how to
do an impression but like other more
passionate romantic cultures are like I
hope you die and then like 5 minutes
later they're having sex that's a
stereotype but I wonder if there's any
truth to it um what was that accent that
you just did right there it was my
attempted Lithuania and I realized I
couldn't do it it kind of came out the
other one where you did wish somebody to
die that was yeah I hope you die I have
so many friends I grew up with you know
Italians and Iranians and all these and
they're all about big gatherings and big
energy I'm not like that like I'm I'm a
pretty private person PPP um what's PPP
you're triple P what's that private
person I'm a pretty private person yeah
that's right you can just say PPP people
know what that means I like it um so but
everyone has those moments and for me so
I was always little angry moments yeah
well you have it you have to get that
out cuz if you hold it in all the time I
actually had in previous relationships
my you know my ex-wife my previous
girlfriends they would say to me like
you know maybe if you you know did show
a little emotion that you know things
would go oh really because well cuz I I
in my first two relationships the entire
relationship fiveyear relationships each
never got in a fight just didn't happen
we'd get in disagreements but I don't I
I was always the um what's the word like
uh when I growing up in our family I was
like the mediator I was the one that
would peeper makes my skin crawl a
little bit because both my wife and I
were the peacekeepers in our families
and I still am that way but I I I wonder
where you're going you think it's better
to fight maybe it is tell me uh well
it's like so Zoe who uh for anybody who
doesn't know is my partner and we just
got engaged um Zoe yes um don't don't
tell we have a new scoop yeah don't tell
Channing uh so um de Chanel and uh she
is the greatest conflict resolutionist
I've ever met in my life because you
have conflict with somebody you'll have
disagreements but it's what you do in
those moments so like you were saying
some people will shout you know I hate
you I you know this you know you're a
child you know you or they'll go into
something about physical things what you
can't come back those for us yeah ex
lumbering ogres your fly is always down
you make Lurch look weird like what
Lurch looks like your after photo you
strive for
Lurch but you know you got to be careful
when you say those things um I mean I do
think you have to get things out nine
out of 10 times if you say something
that's bothering you the response is
better than you thought it would be so
but I think you can say it kindly yeah
exactly you don't have to say it like
douchebag does yeah everything that you
know when we're having our communication
there's never a situation where we're
ever nasty yeah um but there are moments
of blurted out truth and you know I
think the one thing that you feel safe
that's really nice I'm very happy for
you talk about these things I can I
sorry tell me no I'm I'm just saying
like it's it's nice I feel like you have
the same I do you know beliefs about
that I do a very strong I I think you
should feel safe in your relationship
and I think not enough people are
looking for a safe Space Place person
wherein you can make mistakes or you can
I like what you said you can blurt out a
truth sometimes I say to Val I'm just
like I this isn't the entirety of how I
feel I just want to tell you what my
pain is saying my pain says this you
know what I mean but dissociating from
it a little bit but I'll give you an
example we had a bunch of people over
for dinner last night next time you're
in town remember next time you're in
town are you up there what's that do you
not disclose where you live uh we're in
brenwood oh okay yeah so I yeah and
we're in oh I didn't know if you were up
in Ohio fulltime or something yeah we're
up there next time you're in town okay
so we could do that touch from across
the room it's so we could we're not even
in the frame until two legs just come in
and high five but the Baywatch song has
to be playing so people stand I can't
believe you reference is one of my
favorite songs of all time I sing it for
fun it's a great song stand alone so
last night at dinner
I had just been on the road I was in
Salt Lake City this past weekend it's my
first day back I'm giving Val some
contact so she had been alone with the
baby for a couple days 5-year-old but
you know what I mean baby so
understandably Val was a little under
the pressure cooker and she just made
this dinner it was her idea she said
this we talked about it later she was
like I know the dinner was my idea but I
still feeling pressure that I made this
dinner and then the the dog was barking
and we all know the dog is for Valerie I
know you love your dogs but I'm I'm the
one that's like the also ran with the
dog I love the dog but it's sort of like
anyway he's out somewhere barking which
is annoying me and I'm like where's
Brody and Val just goes well maybe you
could go and look for him because I just
sat down like I can't even do the tone
but there was a tone yeah there was like
a
sarcasm and I would say this Val will
listen to this I'm just saying this this
isn't [__] talk there was kind of like a
well I know you've been sitting and
enjoying your meal I'm going to side
with Val in this one I'm I'm with you
that that's why I gave you her context
I'm I'm proud that I gave you her
context I could have been like and she
used a tone I'm telling you I just got
back in town I understand that but I'm
also a sensitive for all my confidence
there's all this sensitivity and the way
that the fight went was I was like um
you can just say that to me like you can
just say what you're feeling you don't
have to imply it you know what I mean is
exactly what I say when that happens is
that real yeah oh yeah you just go like
you can say I'm frustrated I've been Al
you can just say like it's a little
annoying you can say but don't don't
don't use comedy on me I don't like it
cuz I'm I'm we're both fluent in it and
I'm like I know what you're up to you're
frustrated with me just say or you know
what my favorite is and I'm going to
throw this all back to you my favorite
is just like baby love I just sat down
just a little and Val's a genius at that
99.999999% of the time she does that
that's all we need is just a little like
my love I just sat down would you mind
getting him that's all I need but if you
if you cloak it then I go like why are
you cloaking it I'm your home I'm your
safe home yeah and I don't need
renovating so stay the [__] away go on
what what does that make you think this
[__] is renovated she's been renovated
we already have white brick around the
fireplace I so this is my problem is I'm
not a hyper emotional person I'm the
easiest going like I have no problem
doing running out doing this and you
know getting up everything what I don't
like is the
and so I get I get tones are killers man
this is what I get and so uh and my
response is also not very grownup so
that i' I see the fault in how I
communicate this but it'll be something
where I don't know what it would be but
it would be like you know hey did we put
that bowl somewhere in the pantry like
or whatever it is and if the response is
like I don't know where the why would it
I don't know where the bowl is I'm like
don't treat me like yeah I'm an idiot
right it's a legitimate question I don't
know where way because you don't say hey
idiot you can say it with tone yeah and
and that's what that's really what the
issue was is like if you're frustrated
and look we could all strive to be this
way all the time we can't so Val is
totally innocent in this situation what
happened though is my feelings got hurt
and it I'm shocked I might not I'm not
hyper emotional EI I don't know if
that's true but I am hyp sensitive for
sure especially after a weekend of doing
standup you'd think I'd come home and be
like I am Invincible but you're actually
drained we just watched Phantom thread
after he has like his shows and stuff
he's just in bed the next day he just
feels so vulnerable that's how I feel so
the to you're human and I'm human but
especially in social situations Val and
I the the tension that we've had in our
relationship has almost always been if
we're out and I feel like she's paying
attention to everyone except me and I
that's vulnerable to say but that's
where it comes from cuz Val is such a
good reflector and connector that if the
three of us were having dinner there's a
risk we' talk about on the ride over
would' go like just make sure you check
in with me cuz all I need is every once
in a while like like Pete's always
saying or Pete and I talk about this
just something because if I just sit
there and I just start feeling like an
island to your you guys' continent I'll
be like I'm Vanishing I hate this and
then you know what I'll do all the
regular ego stuff I'll I'll brag like
I'll be like yeah I renovated a house
once like classic [__] 80s movie like
villain not not total [__] stuff but
I'd be like I'd say something
inappropriate like hey you're tell you
got a big old ding dong you know just
like to try and get in the mix but this
is helpful to remember [__] are
often just looking for a little bit of
of love like they're hurting not it's
not a pass but like what's the
motivation what do you got uh well I'm
I'm the same like we we approach
conversation a little bit different and
so you we had a dinner party zo yeah
well you and I are literally the same
human being apparently it's quite funny
at a certain height they're just all the
same but um so we had a dinner party
night before last don't worry I also
didn't invite you and but next you live
brw so the uh so she had this really
heartfelt speech that she was making
because she was so thankful for the
people who had come and and and
everybody and and actually most of the
people were brand new we'd never met
them we we wanted to we put it out to
some friends to bring people who we
think would be interesting in this
community and make we'll make
introductions and so it was like you
know 24 people and it was pretty nice
but so you wanted to make new friends
that's fun yeah and and but also let
these people make new friends and create
community and uh so she's making a
heartfelt speech and and at one point I
I cracked a joke and everybody roared
laughing and thought it was really funny
but and it was just something stupid
like she said you know we wanted to
bring in some really incredible people
who we thought would get along and make
new connections and then I said they
weren't available so we chose you guys
and everyone Roar yeah but it's Well
Done For What It's Worth it's it's a
classic kind of style but I like the
wording very much I didn't they weren't
available I didn't think of the fact
that Zoe felt that underminded her um
really beautiful speech that she was
making and that's the problem that I
have how on out of 10 how hard felt was
it was it like she was really this
matters to me this is it does it was
also like she mentioning the world the
world is so lonely and frightening she
there was no Soliloquy but uh did she
have a
ukulele she always has a
ukulele but I think that's the problem I
have is I so the the two things is well
one I believe everyone takes everything
too seriously so I generally don't take
anything too seriously but there are
moments where jokes they're not needed I
even though I don't think the audience
cared I don't think the guests cared
they didn't see a difference but yeah
that's the my weakness is I constantly
crack a joke or I constantly say
something when sometimes it's nice to
have a pure tender moment and not feel
like you got a joke but you couldn't be
talking to someone who understands both
sides of this issue more and I wouldn't
even be like if I say that you in that
moment wanted to share when you say
attention it sounds like a bad thing but
you guys were hosting this is just your
side we'll we'll do zoee side as well
you know what I mean like I'm not this
isn't a one-sided thing no I'm saying I
couldn't relate
more and the joke worked you know what I
mean if it fell flat which it hasn't
there have been like you said RIS so
here's the thing is the risk I am known
I half of what I say on property
brothers could never air because yeah we
just joke around we have a good time
I've got you know I may swear every now
and then and so you're talking about
your balls touching your zi room totally
like you know we're just like but all in
fine like there's never anything
negative on the set but um there have
been moments where I hate this when you
have a new conversation with somebody
new that you just meet and it's always
like this very buttoned up safe
conversation understand tell with that I
act like I've met this person a thousand
times and I know them very well and so
sometimes I'll say something that is
like out of left field yeah and zoee is
like a
very um like very funny but proper yeah
person and we can say we can even make
that a compliment she's classy she's
extremely class and classic classy that
actually is a great description yeah
classy and classic cuz when I there was
a time when it was the three of us and I
was just kind of like enjoying how
classic she was but it did disrupt you
and I we started behaving better we're
both we're we're 13year olds in giant
bodies with adult bank accounts soam
basically the movie Shazam two Shazam
are talking you know there's a time and
place for everything but yeah anyway so
that's the you know there's always this
Dynamic where you know I encour and I
support her in everything that she does
and I love who she is and how she is and
and she supports and loves me it doesn't
mean that sometimes we don't have those
cringy moments where ooh I really read
this room wrong or you know but how so
how did she and I'm I'm setting her up
for Success cuz I feel like it was in a
great way meaning I'm not looking for
dirt how did she say hey I didn't like
that joke and how did you discuss it
well we'll usually just have that
conversation so if there's ever
something where um when did you have it
usually right after like I don't like
having those conversations in the moment
Val used the tone and I was like Hey
like immediately and guess what just to
give you the finale we were fine and
then like 10 minutes later I'm like
washing a dish or something me she gives
me a a rim
job but that's like cleaning you mean oh
I didn't mean rim job I meant she licked
my my [__] oh that's a rim that is I
got it right I got it right I got I got
I got it right she came up and hugged me
very sweetly from behind and I wasn't
like that wasn't the period on the
sentence this the conversation was over
but it was just this tenderness and now
we're kissing and it's so nice it's not
trauma bonding it's not like let's play
this game of cat Mouse it was just like
yeah it's okay I'm your I'm your home
because you want to know something I
don't like I don't like makeup sex when
people always talk about the makeup SE
I'm like no that's not you mean
Stockholm syndrome I don't know it's
basically Stockholm syndrome it's yeah
like you're not you you're not in the
right state I'm like it's like cuz I
take a little time like when I do boil
it takes a and there's very little that
will set me up but when I do boil like I
need a little time to simmer back down
yeah yeah but uh I don't need to be
making love in that in that way and uh
but but angry masturbating is no problem
Furious masturbating is the only
masturbating it's dangerous I'll read
the news and then I'll masturbate just
to be like a the world is so sad like
I'm mad about everything and then I'll
but the I I will say the the the
challenge for me which you know and Zoe
again will be honest about bringing this
up is I don't like to burden people with
things and so I just let things slide
and slide and slide and then eventually
if and when I bring it up yeah well then
you know Zoe will say well why wouldn't
you bring that up in the moment if it
was something's happening and she's
right because I don't want to bother her
I don't want to bother so I just let it
slide it's not like I'm like keeping a
list of these things that one day will
come out I just it to me it doesn't
occupy uh my brain the same way I think
somebody who holds on to a lot of these
things do it just I remember these
things but it's not like eating away at
me yeah yeah it's not super practical
too it's you're you're it sounds very
masculine what you're doing is going
like this isn't really useful this leads
to a a bad conversation or a weird
feeling let's just put it aside and kind
your break down you build them up it's
very and that's very I think that's part
of what makes you a sex symbol guy is
you're like let's sorry right sorry
sorry sorry oh I didn't know what we
were doing I Stone thing right now but
like we love that decisiv let's go in
and fix it and and the I don't know what
to do with this feeling it's not of use
it's not a good tool for what I'm going
for which in the moment is a good day so
I'm going to throw it aside just like I
would like bad wall paper right but like
I think what Zoe would say and certainly
meaning Zoe seems to be representing
what Valerie in my life represents is
there is something potentially inside
you that is keeping score we could call
it your unconscious we could call it
somewhere in your body and that [__] is
real yeah and it it's not healthy it's
like the people who um I even remember
you know I was so upset and hurt uh when
I broke up with an ex a long time ago
and I remember that my I I'm very easy
to forgive I never forget and you know I
know where I put you easy to forgive
people love forgiving me down forgive me
I'm so easy don't worry guys you forgive
quickly I forgive quickly so because I
don't want that eating away at me I
remember my family my friends they were
so mad at this person and ongoing and
they would make comments I'm like it
didn't even happen to them I'm like but
when you hold that kind of resentment
you can't help but have it bring
something negative into you and it eats
away
I'm very good at letting those things go
I don't like it's not like I I will ever
oh well then I'll make back up with this
person and we'll be best friends never
going to happen like I remember what
happened yeah but I don't let it control
me yeah but you're making sure you're
actually forgiving not just in denial
yeah yeah exactly you know that story
that the two monks there's these two
monks it's a short story it's almost
over and the monks were in an order
where they weren't allowed to touch
women it was in all male monasteries
often monasteries are uh but they're
Buddhist and they're walking across a
river and there's a woman who can't
cross the river and she's asking for
help to cross the river and uh the first
monk who vowed not to touch women
ignores her and the second monk the
older monk picks her up on his back and
crosses the river so she doesn't get wet
you can building your own reason why she
couldn't get away and he puts her down
20 30 40 minutes later an hour later
they're walking and the younger monk
says the older monk he goes we took a
vow to not touch women why did you pick
up that woman what are you doing doing
and the older monk said are you still
carrying her I put her down an hour ago
yeah isn't that good that's great isn't
that a good story that's exactly it
isn't that it the whole I think it kind
of all comes back again to um how any we
let anything affect us and most people
carry around so much baggage guilt yeah
uh for things that have happened in the
past there's nothing you can do about
try work that's why I think therapy is
great I think when you know when people
go and they talk talk about these things
in a healthy environment it's so
important because a lot of times your
buddies or your girlfriends they're not
actually helping you when they're just
like they just they're telling you what
you want to hear that's right they yes
and it they go B [__] it's it's what
what did you think you were going to say
it's that's not really helpful no it's
not my therapist I've told many people
would just go who cares that's what he
said about almost everything and it was
so helpful I had a a drug a psychedelic
experience where I was like and this is
true right here and now I was like
you're you're high right now I'm high on
drugs I'm high on how many of me are
there right now which one of you said
that no but it was like we are the ones
that create the pass by we we drag it
yeah we and it is like dragging Santa's
bag but it's not filled with toys it's
filled with [__] and you drag it in
and again I hear Val's voice saying like
we can have compassion this is is your
protector so your protector which is an
aspect of your ego you could say is like
going like well Jonathan got hurt by
someone with these qualities yeah right
you mentioned a breakup so maybe you did
file away like look out for this type of
treatment it might be indicative of this
kind of person we don't know but I'm
going to it's like a it's like an
internal government and your elected
president is like we will not be Fooled
Again bu a woman that wears slap
bracelets you know what I mean like
they're doing the best they sometimes
that's all they have slab bracelets mean
narcissistic personality s to vote for
me and you're the one that votes are we
going to keep this legislation anyway
this metaphor goes on and on and on so
but what I'm saying
is that there's a reason for it and we
can even love the fact that our brain is
trying to hold on to grudges to a
certain extent to a helpful extent and
and when it comes to relationships
that's why you know Zoe and I didn't
find each other until our 40s and um it
was funny because you know late 40s yeah
and then you look in the
camera barely I've had work done
everybody knows uh no do work and You'
had work we were talking about how you
know we were both married before and you
know had many relationships and and
whatnot and the problem is when you're
younger you don't know what you want in
a relationship and you know I had
relationships where I was like is this
normal is this are we supposed to be
like this and I'm feeling isolated I
don't feel listened to and then you
which by the way I think are echoes of
past patterns like when you're in a
weird relationship I think you might
have been attracted to it not you I'll
say me because it's the type of abuse
you're used to which is totally true
you're just like oh this is familiar
like how many people did you know that
used to constantly date horrible men or
horrible women and like it's it it's
true you see this pattern but I think
you learn and so I got to a point where
I finally decided I'm like I'm not going
to put up with that [__] I'm not
perfect I know I'm not perfect but I'm
not going to put up with these Baseline
things that deal breakers yeah and
they're not like they're really not like
anything other than personality like if
somebody doesn't respect you enough to
understand that you have emotions you
have a right to feel a certain way if
somebody doesn't they're either a
narcissist and they don't give a [__]
right um or they're so inexperienced in
in love and emotion that I'm too mature
for that and I don't want to be with
somebody like that right and it's not
mean no it's not mean it's just being
honest defending or or what I'm hearing
actually when you make statements like
that is just like self-love work and
that doesn't mean narcissism that just
means like I think what I what's so
important that you're touching on is
it's us that goes you know what it's
like the president new leg new uh what's
it called new government I'm gonna have
a new government and this government is
running on a campaign that I'm worthy of
respect safety spaciousness
curiosity humor but like really I safety
covers so much of it like somebody where
I can feel still excited still excited
and interested but like a lot of us are
going for someone like i' I've been cut
here like I kept getting cut here would
you cut me there and you make these
weird sort of agreements and it takes a
moment where you do it no one else I
know this sounds like a [__]
inspirational talk I'm just saying like
it was an epiphany for me to realize
that it's me yeah that decides you could
say you deserve the life you want yeah
you deserve the partner you want any
people can say that but until you go
like no I do and it's like I was saying
about dragging the past yeah Alan wat
says we're under no obligation to be the
person we were five minutes ago well I'm
just I'm not a happy I'm it doesn't work
out for it's like there are other other
people I'm a huge I don't know I'm happy
that you got out of the things that you
got out of well I think you know you and
what they taught you you analyze even
from the dating I mean
remember it got to a point where things
were so crazy as well and also there
were because as soon as you get physical
with a partner it also changes the
relationship too so I dated a lot of
people and I never would let it get
there because I didn't trust that it was
going to be a safe place to get there
sex sexual yeah sexually like if once
that you do that change that Dynamic so
that's very interesting I'm usually the
first person to say it's like glue yeah
as soon as you start uh getting in the
bone Zone like it can be I was not a one
like a first what do you call it like
one night stand type of person that's I
was never like that and but even in that
I would go out and if there's any
inkling I remember I was out with this
one person and I'd known her socially
through other people and whatnot and
anyway we went out for dinner and she
spent the entire dinner making fun of
the strangers in the restaurant
literally like their physical attributes
the way they were talking and it I was
so confused I'm like is the
conversation that dull that you want to
make fun of this elderly couple that's
over here it was really weird so at the
end of the day I remember I said to I'm
like and you know Zoe and I are both the
same as the fact that we're very
straightforward and that can offend
people but I said to to this woman I
said I don't think this is a match I
don't think we should do this again um
you know thank you for dinner but I
think this is the last time and she lost
it on me she threw a drink at he called
me an [__] in the middle of the
restaurant I don't like it when people
are looking at me and I don't like when
eyes every eye in the restaurant came
and turned and whatever and you know I I
end it because I think she wanted to
continue to another bar and have drinks
and everything and I was like that's the
end of the the date and uh you know it
was horrible like she made a whole scene
and what kind of drink was it it was
wine yeah red wine yeah white wine white
wine thank God yeah yeah that actually
gets stands out none of my wardrobe is
expensive so I'm totally fine with that
I can't believe it so you didn't see
that coming at all you were like hey I
just want to I didn't see it coming but
you know that for me it was like I'm
always I'm analyzing things early on and
I was like it got to a point where I'm
like yeah nope this is definitely a
noggo it's never happening again that's
like look and I believe you did it
compassionately that is the most caring
thing you can do so much of us are are
tied up and locked up and it's like well
we did I think they want to go this bar
and you'll lead them on you'll even
maybe sleep with them because you're
like I think that's what they're
expecting when you can really just be
real and be like let's not postpone no
well actually you know what's
interesting is I so a friend of mine um
who I've known for many many years and
she's um always said to me she's like my
she's like that little person that sits
on your shoulder and gives you advice
and whatever I remember I was dating
somebody and I was very clear because I
had gotten out of a long relationship I
was not interested in I actually didn't
even date for about 6 months after my um
when I was married before yeah when I
split from from that but I went out I
was was almost exactly as long as I
waited to yeah and it's like got to a
point where cuz I held a lot of
resentment toward in general toward
women in relationships because of what
had happened from you know that
relationship and my previous was there a
headline to that was it infidelity or
anything it nothing this isn't a gossip
podcast my wife cheated on me I was
looking for common ground not SC it's um
you know it's not it's more just uh you
know I I realized that it's a problem I
had with the person and it happens to be
that I had been with a couple of people
that you know did not jive with me very
well at all but um finally when I
started dating again I was very clear
and I said I'm not looking for anything
serious it's nice to have company it's
nice to to go and do things see shows
and do whatever you're going to do and I
remember I I said to my friend I'm like
well I know that this person is trying
to lock me down and they want to and
they said oh yeah I'm totally fine with
that nothing serious it's fine and I
said I know that they want to change me
they want to change my mind and that's
their goal and she said well then don't
you think you're really leading them on
and I said no I am literally saying to
her face I said I'm not interested in
any relationship I just want company so
we can go and do shows and everything
and she's like yeah but you know in the
back of your mind that she wants it
otherwise and I said but why is that on
me I'm the one who's being honest and
forward she's the one who's trying to
change me and it's an interesting
Dynamic and depending on who you talk to
everyone is on one side of the other so
I finally got to a point where I didn't
want to play any of those games if I
sniffed out that somebody wasn't being
truthful there was no other no second
day you I think that's really
interesting I also agree with your
little friend your shoulder friend cuz
it's not fair but if you if I build a
cube and it's filling slowly with water
and you get in it and I say if you stay
in here too long you'll drown but I have
to trust you'll get
out before you drown and then it looks
like they're GNA drown it is my it's
still my Cube and my water yeah my
inability to commit is still the water
that's going to hurt them so even if
they're lying and I understand why
they're not being fully honest because
how many relationships do start with
like we dated they didn't want to be
serious or we dated and we thought it
was just this and it turned into this or
or we thought we were friends and isn't
that sort of the superpower not just of
women but anybody with like feminine
intuition that can go I actually think
think I know what you need better than
what the nurturing element of it
nurturing and and by the way I don't
know I can't really speak to that with
Valen I but like there was certainly Val
and I were into each other very quickly
it went at the same Pace but I would
have understood if she was like if I was
like and I don't know about this I think
she would have been like all right fine
but she would have known well and it's
funny because you go through different
periods in your life I was single for a
very long time and I've been burned by
people and I I've been in relationships
too and they're absolutely wonderful
people and there just wasn't the spark
that I was looking for and uh but what's
so funny is so I'd been single for a
long time before meeting Zoe and then
Zoe Barnes yes from House of Cards yeah
she's dead what yeah the president
pushed her in front of a Subway oh my
God yeah Zoe Barnes is she's also
fictional so it's double bad she never
existed and she doesn't exist in the way
she didn't exist in the first place well
I date a lot of fictional people yeah
yeah and it's real
hot the way to keep it safe um no it's
uh now I totally forgot what I was
talking about that's good hosting right
there yeah the greatest I'm going to win
a pu W yeah um and we'll find it we're
talking about being honest the cube
water when you met so we had so I I had
been single for quite a while and my
publicist convinced me to do this
article for People magazine about being
ready for love because I was ready for
love but I'm like I don't necessarily
need somebody that was that story and it
says Jonathan Scott I'm going to show
you this I'm ready for love I'm not
joking I'm hold on I is isn't it
embarrassing when you can Google
something faster about yourself than you
can pull up on your own phone my
daughter and I were making a colog
Jonathan Scott People magazine White
Horse you're on a white horse on the
beach on a white horse in a sunset ready
for love it's so embarrassing and zo so
there so did you do multiple set up I'm
not joking so this is a had Zoe seen
that article about me she would never
have dated me I guarantee you because it
was it was really Che we met three
months we met three months after that
came out it takes three months to live
this down I mean I'm still living it
down I'm on a horse in Mexico on the
beach a white horse and this horse is
tired looking yeah that horse is and you
look you look like you're about to
attend Tony seminar you look magnificent
anyway that's what I was saying is like
tell me did were you worried that would
be the cover well that so my whole thing
was I get it I get sometimes why
publicists have different you know
things they want to do
and sometimes I'm a little too
susceptible like a little too
accommodating for some things but anyway
it didn't affect Zoe when we met we
actually met on carpal karaoke we it was
Zoe and her sister Emily it was Drew and
me and it was sisters and the brothers
and we had a blast and Zoe James what's
that James Cordon yeah uh it was uh the
show on Apple that he had done oh it was
the show so he wasn't there no exactly
and was your song we did a we did the a
whole series of songs everything from
Proclaimers 500 Miles like we like so
Linda ronad like we had so many song we
actually went back so they had Zoe and
me just the two of us go back and do a
kind of where they now and we won an
Emmy for it uh no no we started dating
almost immediately wait your
relationship went an
Emmy pretty much yes
I mean not the first one they're like we
don't know about this relationship but
the second one did when you get married
will the Amy officiate uh I think that's
how works I think you don't have to pay
it cuts to the crowd it's just Golden
Gloves on one side and Oscars on the
other well we don't give each other vows
we give each other emys yeah yeah yeah
and sag residuals yeah exactly I think
so I understand Jonathan has written his
own sag residuals I'm really I'm really
bad with all the technicalities of I am
planning a wedding right now zo are
planning our wedding and we we're so
like
we've been there before we're like you
know what we just want to have a kickass
party second wedding's the best with the
people we really care about hello I'm
talking to second wedding second wedding
is the only good it's the only good
wedding what do you think you're going
to enjoy your first wedding ridiculous
get the [__] out of here that's like
losing your virginity second wedding is
like all right I know a couple moves and
they're all just I want people to have a
fun time can I give you one piece of
unsolicited advice that Val really
nailed for our wedding absolutely you
just want your wedding to look like your
love and if you think about you're
inviting people into your this sounds
like something someone would say on your
show but like like what it feels like
meaning not Fanci or sparkling I just
mean like warm is it sloppy is it sweaty
is there a ukulele on every seat no uh
our wedding was very like folky it was
kind of Blu grassy it was it was outside
it everybody had to pick up their chairs
from the and take it over to the table
wine barrels it was in a Vineyard and
and a big tree and twinkle lights very
not not super fancy it wasn't like a
like that but it was warm and it sort of
had a fantastic M Mr Fox kind of flavor
because that movie manales and that vibe
that Wes Anderson kind of feeling anyway
so when people come to the wedding and
they're celebrating and bearing witness
to you guys and enjoying it if it feels
like this little ecosystem of you guys
and then it then it's not like planning
a party it's more like what do we look
like what do we look like as a couple I
love that because the one thing that Zoe
and I have bonded over is we both love
to entertain and we this is my one
humble brag that I'm allowed we throw
the best parties we throw amazing dinner
parties we love doing it she's very
creative and and when we do it all
ourselves she does tablescapes and and I
handle you know the entertainment stuff
and uh but for the wedding I agree with
you it doesn't have to be the fanciest
thing it doesn't have to be anything I
also don't subscribe what you look like
if you look like white marble in an
indoor waterfall then go for it golden
toilets and calak what were you going to
say oh I was just I was going to say
like I don't subscribe to allowing your
the people around you to also dictate
what you have to do at your wedding
that's [__] right second wedding yeah
if somebody you know I there I have
family that I've never met I've got
distant I'm like I'm I'm literally if if
if I haven't had dinner or a sleepover
with you in the last year yeah let me
say it for you bye bye it's [__] by
we want to keep it simple can I tell you
the healing my first wedding was all
[__] this and this [__] I don't
want to say any titles you know what
family members they were they all came
to the first one I have from my first
wedding I don't look at these pictures
obviously but like I know there are
pictures of just miserable lithuanians
like looks like it should be in black
and white hell you know like just like
why the [__] are you at my wedding I'll
tell you why we were hoping you'd give
us some cash and you didn't cuz we were
22 and broke but anyway that's not even
true you were there because my parents
said that's the done thing you know and
now our second wedding the healing and
it goes back to what you were saying
about relationships when you realize
that that's all nonsense I have to
invite who my parents say or I have to
to date someone that hurts me it's the
same yes mechanism that goes like that
it's like my drug experience we don't
have to drag that aspect of the past
into this this is a fresh this one this
is a fresh moment with arrows in every
direction you can go in any direction
and they say well you have to invite so
and so and you're like Roberta your
friend from church will not be at the
wedding you know what I mean like feels
[__] great only aist baby yeah
exactly Al but also so it's not on me to
worry about someone else feeling like
their feelings are hurt because they
they weren't invited and and that's
Water by the way that is not on you no
it's not but also like sometimes you'll
have pressure from family members like
no you have to do like no I really don't
because I could also elope and not do
the wedding at all but you know we we
want to have we want to spend time with
friends and family and and whatnot and I
I do remember there are certain like
from my my first wedding uh the one
thing that it should have been a red
flag for me and I I kind of like glossed
over and everything but I'm Scottish
proud of my Scottish Heritage I did wear
a kilt the wedding we had this beautiful
outdoor setting friends let us use their
place on a lake it was gorgeous she
forbid me from having bag pipes play WoW
at any point during the wedding we were
literally out on a lake in the perfect
setting I get that it's too loud in a
church or something but we were out on a
lake at first setting I'm all was a
foggy Lake cuz if it's a foggy Lake
there was a
castle it was and I remember thinking to
myself I'm like and so you know Zoe and
I have talked about the stuff that we
want to do and and and speaking of
Castle I proposed at Edinburgh Castle
you did not yeah I had a whole thing I
had a pipe band set up it was all we
cleared the castle we were the only
people there A bag pipe yeah yeah see
that's healing that's the punchline to
that story first wedding no bag pipes
second engagement bring in the bag pipes
she literally knows
um the things that are important to me
the things that have hurt me I've had
other relationships too where the same
the person ended up doing the same thing
that hurt me in a previous relationship
and they knew that that was what
happened in a previous and they still
did it right and so that's what I think
is so incredible when you find somebody
who knows your sensitivities who knows
what has hurt you and they vow to never
do that no that's exactly right my first
wife like I said it was infidelity and
she left me and as much as I've been
therapized and healed and and it's been
a long time all of those things Val
knows she just has to tell me I'm not
going to leave you she just has to say
it yeah like because I get there's like
a little wounded 28-year-old still in me
somewhere and she just goes baby I'm not
I'm not going to leave you I'm not going
to leave you and I'm just like that's my
bag pipes yeah I know that sounds silly
but like no that's exactly when you find
the healing element yeah and it is and
it is something to be be said for it
being verbalized because [__] people
will think it but they don't say it I'm
like you realize like when you're saying
when you're at a party it it is
important for those little gestures to
show that you're thinking of the other
person you're car you haven't just just
a foot under the table yeah that's all I
need I I I am not a glutton for I am a
glutton for attention to my work but in
my regular life because Val and I talked
about this if she just touches my hand
or if she just if I touch her hand and
she holds it yeah it's it's it's funny
how quickly we can just a th unravel if
we the scotum something just a thumb
right to the taint you push up and you
go it's the male she still loves me
yeah thanks for stopping me from saying
male gspot yeah and then I brought it up
anyway what's interesting is that Zoe
disel is a theme for a wedding like I
guarantee people have said to wedding
planners make my wedding look like it's
Zoe de Chanel's wedding because she has
a and I mean all of this as a compliment
I don't mean it as like a phony like
brand but I mean she has a look she has
an aesthetic oh she's stylish person
because she's a a musician so once if
you listen to She and Him or or her
Christmas albums what all that stuff and
you go make it look like that yeah I can
I can already see it I can already see
the slogan new guy and girl that's the
wedding new guy and girl wait no she and
him and him She and Him she and them she
and them both of them and it's you and
your brother yeah wait a sec no it's
true it's uh it actually was pretty
incredible because uh she has even when
we were designing our house we were
renovating for three years on our home
to here to get done like the Winchester
House you know that one yeah yeah oh
yeah oh yeah I still want to go I
they've invited me to go there yeah
exactly but uh no they um I've never
trusted anybody else to design anything
within the walls of the home I live in
and I discovered that Zoe has incredible
taste and so she picked a lot of the
wallpapers and the fixtures and hardware
and stuff like that and then I could
focus on the architectural and the
construction side but it was great we
have a very symbiotic relationship that
way where we lean on each other even
when we're doing we're obsessed with
Escape rooms we do Escape rooms all the
time just the two of us wow and I'm very
fast I'm very very quick I've done
hundreds of them all over the world and
I love it it but skip steps you're like
I bet the keys in there and I bet it's
over there and I bet I bet it just says
it's behind the clock yeah yeah I
literally do but you're not oh was right
and so Zoe is very she's slow but
meticulous and she'll go through and
she'll pick up all the things that I
missed and it ends up being this perfect
relationship where we kind of we respect
each other's weaknesses but we also
support each other's strengths and you
might want to work that into your vows
cuz that just made me a little emotional
cuz a relationship is like an escape
room and you want a good partner in your
Escape no no no I don't mean it like
that I me no no I'm I'm literally
thinking in my mind because I haven't
written my vows yet I'm like you want to
have a partner that is bringing
something else that was missing so if
I'm in an escape room it's exactly how
Val and I are not to compliment us again
but I'm just like I love our I love our
love and I am this and I sort of am like
I'm high processing I'm fast I'm this
I'm he I'm top down she's bottom up and
she brings me into my body and she
brings in all this like wisdom she's the
one that goes like you need to slow down
she's the one that says like I don't
think you need to do that I are you're
missing this and this and so she's
literally like
waking me up to life and then I'm and I
would say this if she was here again
like I'm making her feel safe I know
that's very heteronormative or whatever
it is but like I'm protecting her and
providing for her so she can blossom but
it's just so I it might and I'm not even
talking necessarily about financials I'm
just saying like I got you I believe in
you I say it to her all the time I
believe in you you to be able to do that
for each other that's that's the whole
thing I I've been in relationships where
I was the only one
constantly supporting and and and
engaging and you know doing all of these
things to show support and it wasn't
reciprocated yeah and you eventually it
chips away at you to the point where
your emotional Foundation is Rocky and
I'm say it person too yeah sorry yeah no
I I think it's it's important to to say
things and you know what that thing is
so funny is I'm not a gift person I
don't like gifts I don't like gifts
either yeah I I find it I don't even
know what to say sometimes when people
get cuz I don't like gifts I have the
things that I need but you know if it's
if someone makes like a creative a
creative will write me a poem yeah but
what I was thinking is some people they
feel like the only way to show gifts
gifts gifts gifts yeah the value of a
written note or a poem or even just some
kind words in an unexpected moment yeah
worth way more I agree than a well maybe
not a brand new Lamborghini but a
I'd rather have the lambo baby no
honestly uh no if somebody gave me a
Lamborghini I I would get rid of it
immediately uh but if somebody said like
new electric one looks like the
Batmobile by the way does it really yeah
which one which Batmobile uh the like
the big sexy curves long the long body
frame on it it looks that's you mean Tim
Burton Batman yeah like 86 yeah yeah or
whatever that was 89 little more
straight edges but any I just thought
that would be appropriate seeing his
right behind you is Batman and there's
Batman behind you I call them
Batman pardon the interruption weirdos
this episode is brought To Us by our
friends at the perfect Jean sorry to
keep talking about my Netflix special
but of course I'm wearing the perfect
Jean in my Netflix special I am not for
everyone because they look incredible
and they feel incredible it's the 21st
century I don't know why we can't wear
comfortable pants that also look good
but you know in the past your options
were yoga pants like Sting or Phil
Collins or something but now we have
jeans that look like designer jeans with
ultra ultra high quality craftsmanship
craftsmanship I never have to replace my
my perfect jeans and I wear them every
single day and they're buttery soft
silky smooth and give you stretch so
your so your man Parts aren't crushed
these are the best pands I've ever owned
no lie I own so many pairs and so many
different washes even their khaki wash
which is incredible I love a light khaki
it looks like eggs but it's that soft
Genie material Genie yeah the genie
material and what do they do they uh sew
in 2% Spandex and 2.5% rayon for for a
sneaky for a sneaky stretchy secret that
no one needs to know they I wear them to
Red Carpet Events I wear them to TV
tapings obviously but they feel like
pajamas isn't that the Best of Both
Worlds no one needs to know you're
basically wearing a like a baby's onesie
it's so soft you'll forget you're
wearing pants it's actually I I have to
say that legally you might forget you're
wearing pants they're incredible they
look awesome they fit awesome they last
forever and they spare your nuts
perfectly perfect jeans for the
imperfect man 20% off when you use code
weirdo at checkout liberate your lower
limbs protect your lower lentils whether
you got a little Clover or a honken
eggplant it doesn't matter they got you
covered and you're going to look good
while you're doing it uh support the
show support your lower half go to the
perfect Jean J EA an the perfect gene.
NC that's the perfect gene. NC and use
code weirdo for 20% off at checkout
those guys are incredible it's also
brought To Us by our friends at ritual
the only multivitamin that I've ever
taken that I don't just get the feeling
that I'm immediately peeing it out you
know when you take a a multivitamin and
the next time you pee it's like the
color of a highlighter and you're like
well there that goes ritual has figured
that out you take it it's got a delayed
release so it waits until it's in your
lower intestine to break down so it can
actually be absorbed and the proof is in
the pudding I used to go to the doctor
and they were like you're deficient in
this this this this ritual has got me
covered and it gets me ready feeling
great to start my day it's traceable
scientifically developed with high
quality key nutrients in bioavailable
forms the ingredients are you are
traceable like I said knowing where they
came from what do we got in there
D3 DHA omega-3 DHA for muscle function
immune function with D3 B12 hard to get
if you don't eat meat B12 traceable
vegan friendly non-GMO sugar-free
gluten-free major allergen free and as I
said they delay the release which is a
game change it's a minty Essence in
every bottle that keeps taking them a
pleasure there's a minty aftertaste so
it's actually enjoyable it's not some
disgusting pharmaceutical smelling horse
pill that you have to force down it's a
pleasure to take in the morning I also
take their synbiotic plus prepost and uh
prepost and there's three biotics it's
like a pro oh Pro probiotic for gut
health and I take their multis for men
every single day Val takes their women
she also took their prenatal when she
was pregnant this is a great
multivitamin if you've resisted in the
in the past I get it ritual has solved
those problems you can support your body
and support the show ritual is giving
weirdos 30% off during your first month
visit ritual.com weird to start ritual
or add essential to men for men sorry
add essential for men to your
subscription today that's ritual.com
weird all right everybody back to
Jonathan
Scott is um again not a gossip podcast
do you think Zoe will sing at your
wedding because that's an interesting
one if I'm coming to your wedding which
I'm assuming I'm not because I love your
credentials [__] Pals deep the Deep
friends wait when's our last sleepover
that we had this podcast is surprisingly
long I would buy a SC I don't think I'd
fit on this couch you absolutely
wouldn't why is that one cushion
backwards that's going to bug me there's
a stain on it but it could go the other
rotate it's the zippers forward zippers
back people tell me something about your
house when you designed it we'll fix
that don't do it now Katie you know
there's spiders in that
c wait you just told me to sleep on that
c well I want you to be devoured by
devoured by spiders uh what is something
in your house that you guys again just
for I never answer your question tell me
I don't know that Zoe will sing at the
wedding um I
love every thing she sings everything
she plays our house I designed it so we
listen to her for two months November
December it's just greatest holiday
album it's the greatest holiday albums
ever but um we were talking about that
and I don't know I I want us to have a
night where we don't have to be on like
it you know we can enjoy each other so
we haven't even talked about that stuff
yet but I don't know I don't know if she
will or not yeah it's
interesting I I'm thinking through I I
like I didn't I wouldn't have wanted to
do a funny toast my vows weren't very
funny you know what I mean you that was
enough performance and then the rest of
it was ice cream and dancing oh here's
another tip ready for a tip yes this is
a good tip I don't even I'm not going to
apologize for the ice cream after the
dancing no no fill your butt crack with
the ice cream okay then have a box of
hungry squirrels wait yes
[Laughter]
no uh this is a tip that our I wish I
could remember the name of our wedding
planner but she said what you do is
because what's a great wedding I mean
maybe you differ on this but a great
wedding is one where everyone dances MH
you get first of all [__] bangers
only what is this [__] [__] with
wedding DJs playing sleeper hits and
[__] Beyonce Play Beyonce like just
[__] do it let's go play Crazy In
Love play these are the things that Val
and I like to dance to but regardless of
your music
choices after the ceremony uh you guys
have come out you've been announced get
everyone on the dance floor for a photo
take a huge group photo then play the
song play the song everyone has to dance
to while everyone's on the dance floor
for the photo brilliant idea and it just
it just happens and next thing you know
instead of three brave people dancing
out of the hundred let's say 75 are
going to stay on the Dance Floor the old
people are going to shuffle off to
Buffalo well and we're we're actually
going to um put psychedelics into the
desserts say as well yeah that just kind
of kicks things off to if you had a
wedding where everyone was on on MDMA
that would be incredible it would also
lead to an orgy which would be weird
you'd be like who family yeah exactly
well which is also an interesting thing
too because so we recently just did a a
holiday we went through you know
Scotland and England and oh I saw that I
saw that on your soci you were in the
woods that you played in yeah well
exactly was very sweet so that's lanarch
where we were born we were Sor my dad
was born and um so our family is all
from lanarch it turns out Zoe's Mom's
family is from Blackwood which is 10
minutes away from there no way so
there's a 31% chance that we're distant
cousins so who knows but we won't talk
about that it's so hot so hot I didn't
think you guys were going to make it
until just now cuz that is the kind of
heat you can't fake no 30% chance that
is oh that's very funny I thought that
was real science no no let me ask you
this uh I need to know what is your Elf
watching policy
because look you can't have Christmas
without Watching Elf you can't agreed
you have so that means you have to watch
it with her is she able to watch Elf no
she doesn't like to watch herself but um
you got to deep fake it deep fake
[__] Katy Perry on her
face so we have there's a few films over
the holidays that are like my go-to I
love Elf I love a Wonderful Life got to
do it with Zoe you got to do it with her
well the funny thing is now the kids are
at an age where their friends are now
realizing that Zoe is an elf and they
watch it and they love it and so a lot
like we'll go to the kids school
yesterday we an event at the kids school
and other kids will run up and they'll
just be like start waving hi Zoe andan
girls what's that yeah six h d yeah and
uh it's it's hilarious and it's cute so
we uh we don't really we don't watch a
lot of TV and stuff like in general I
don't even watch TV at all unless I'm
like on a plane or something usually um
good murder show before bedtime but
that's about it something to really
haunt you yeah but uh no we um you know
the holiday movies you need to tell her
this first of all it's blonde Zoe she
won't even recognize herself and she's
like what 20 years old in it yeah there
enough time has passed she needs to
watch help this is real yeah she doesn't
know what she's doing do I use that tone
and pitch that play this clip Zoe desel
has to watch Elf I get it oh we're all
Adam Driver and we can't watch ourselves
you need to watch Elf if Adam Driver was
elf he'd watch Elf yeah because it's
Christmas it's not Christmas without elf
I want to see Adam Driver as elf now
that's you just put that in my head S I
can't do it I can hear it I can hear it
in my head yeah s
that was so good oh my God love Adam
it's a very different flavor I hope you
find your dad say hi to your dad my dad
left
me it's just very intense I know what I
have to do but I don't know if I have
the strength to do it yes anyway I I
don't I think I've heard lore of that
movie like they didn't think it was
working do you have any inside scoop on
that which movie Elf I heard like the
production was kind of like I I think
this is what I think I heard I'm not
even putting it to you we're just two
guys
talking that because I really know
nothing like I know that's why I'm just
forget that we're not looking for
Insider info is what I mean I heard that
like will thought they were making a
very different movie from what they were
making yeah and that it wasn't you know
there's that horror cut of Elf the
trailer have you have you seen that oh
you got to goog it somebody it's one of
the great ones you know they say comedy
and horror movies the only difference is
the music yeah so you can cut elf into a
very good horror trailer really I mean
think about it zo in the shower and he's
coming in and you just like the raccoon
that jumps on his face terrifying is I
mean you're kidding but that gave me
nightmares all right I got like they're
like something's wrong with them and
it's like this Christmas I do remember
uh reading as well the same thing that
that it apparently wasn't an easy road
to make that movie and uh there were a
lot of like changes and even in edit I
believe that they had to go through
through a lot of passes and and I think
they realized kind of late wait this is
a family movie yeah and you can sort of
you can sort of tell like it seemed like
it was like maybe he's a little we like
not not Twisted but like something's
wrong with this guy yeah and then they
were like no it's magical it's Christmas
magic yeah any I mean it is one of the
great Christmas movies I do love it and
Josh rubben do you know Josh Rubin he's
one of the funniest people ever he's in
the crowd during the news scene and we
always spot Josh Rubin he's great great
Peter Dinklage old dinkies dinkies in
there uh yeah you got Adam or not Adam
um uh oh my God uh the dad no co uh
Conan's oh Andy right Andy Andy um Adam
um but who's the dad because that's a
classic James con James KH yeah yeah he
he was great uh yeah I that's the whole
thing is like you know I actually do
play through coming over here I was
playing a throwback jams mix uh
and I'm like for me I love the genre I
grew up in the music my parents play at
the holidays it's B Crosby It's natkin
Cole and you know the movies that we
would watch you know It's a Wonderful
Life um you know um what's the other one
uh with Scrooge um Bill Murray no no no
the original with aliser Sim oh like I
like the uh Christmas Carol yeah all of
these just brings back a sense of
nostalgia well my hope is you know that
the kids will keep coming back to the
house and they'll keep you know we have
the holidays we have everything happen
they'll love those Traditions they'll
love those memories and we'll have those
moments our family there's not really a
lot of drama in our family you know our
our parents were pretty strict growing
up and everything but we have these
Beautiful Moments these beautiful family
memories and I love that our parents
have now moved here and so we can
actually spend time together again but
that's important for me and so all the
chaos and the craziness and everything
goes on yeah holidays are my favorite
time because I love the music I love the
movies I love the the food and that's
that's what's important to me yeah I'm
going for it this year every year I make
the pledge this is going to be the
Christmas it always makes me a little
depressed yeah I get because it REM look
I'm not trying to [__] on my family I'm
just saying like it it as a group we
weren't always jelling yeah I'll say
that and the holidays was always like
the time we spent the most time together
and there was all this pressure and well
that's why they always say you know
family like holiday dinners are always
like the Catalyst for every major family
argument and it's true I don't know what
it and I I would see a lot of that uh
could happen for extended periods of
time because you get people together and
you know inevitably you know you bring
in pressure of gifts and stuff and look
we're talking about that's why I don't
like gifts yeah no I'm with you part of
the reason though dude is why I don't
like gifts is because I saw that it's
not for everybody and I really wish this
is compassion I'm not [__] on my
parents I'm like I wish we could have
been like look we're not great at gifts
that's okay let's let's do something
else maybe we're a trip maybe we should
go on a trip on Christmas or something I
don't know how you could have saved my
family's Christmas but what we did was
Christmas Eve Barnes & Noble and it's
[__] sad and so like when I went to
Val I don't mean to change the whole
subject but when I went to Val's house
for Christmas and they're great at
Christmas they'll give you a thing that
you mentioned six months ago like
they're great at gifts yeah or even if
they're like swing shots in the dark
they're based on something you might
like like but not just your obvious
interested no like a lower level
interest or a book that you wanted to
read good at that and it's like
emotional for me and I'm like there was
something it took a toll on me to like
shop for my mom on Christmas Eve 10
minutes from the house and they wrap it
and every year we give her a cat
calendar I mean even saying that makes
me just want to jump in a furnace like I
can't stand it but going back to the
theme of this entire
conversation okay so no bag pipes bag
pipes and then no good gifts I'm a great
gift giver and I'm faking it you know
what you do you just write it down
that's all a great Gift Giver is you
just have a folder in your phone called
Val she could find it at any moment and
see what I've been because I'm not
naturally good at it but you put the
effort in and the effort is only a
result of the trauma so I can't even
fault the trauma the trauma was the
engine that led to Improvement in the
same way are uh not as successful
relationships let's not even call them
failed they just they weren't longterm
or permanent relationships led to the US
that could say like you know what
Christmas this year is going to be
[__] great and having kids is great
for that because you're like it's all
about Leela I don't totally about them
it's like a second wedding you go like
we don't need Roberta there and and now
it's just about making Leela believe in
Sandy cross you know it you were saying
a second ago about you know failing in
relationships and I never understood why
failure was cuz you're you're kind of
taught in certain you know uh periods
throughout your life that failure is bad
failure is bad every successful person
in business has failed way more than
they've succeeded yeah why can't that be
accepted the same in relationships you
can't get to a great relationship yeah
without having a bunch of failures
that's how you evolve and adapt you
don't even you said it you don't even
know what you want no you didn't know
what you wanted and you were still
unconsciously reenacting trauma
ritualistically reenacting traumas
because that was what was familiar and
they can be small traumas I don't mean
like abuse necessarily I just mean like
oh that's familiar but guess what the
the fish bowl you were raised in isn't
as fun as the ocean [__] break the
bowl you don't need to bring the bowl
exactly and it's also too like I I see
what you mean about having like you know
holiday memories that aren't really
something that you get excited about or
whatever yeah um in my mind I have
certain situations in and and
particularly places that I visited with
previous partners that really kind of
Tainted that place that I really did
like and now it's like and in my mind
I'm like is it that I would never want
to go there again because I don't want
to relive that or do I go and make a new
memory recla that's yeah reclaim it
exactly it can you do that with a
holiday can you do that with a location
I love that you I really feel seen thank
you for hearing me cuz that's what I'm
trying to do I'm trying to rip up a flag
it was a fine flag it's not a failure
it's just I just want a different flag
in Mount Christmas and it's funny you've
inspired me because I've had
places that I thought were ruined by
like fights like I had a again I used to
just get screamed at I was I wasn't much
of a fighter I I was like more of a
Chandler I'd wait for a pause and say
something horrible but say it Cal would
pour gasoline on The
Inferno yeah and one of those happened
at the Grove I remember just being
screamed at at the Grove I was like you
ever see a couple just having a real
fight at the [__] Grove well I was
that guy oh wow and everybody was like
yikes let's go to let's go to [__] PF
JS and forget we saw that but I can go
to the Grove now but that that's a dumb
example but there are there are vacation
spots places that You' think like well
that that's ruined and then more and
more that you embody this perspective
there's an aid Brothers song it's like I
don't know if it's Aid no it isn't Aid
Brothers song but it's talking about how
all of those experiences like pave the
road that lead you where you're going
that's exactly and nothing like me
saying I'm a good Gift
Giver because my family was really bad
at
it what doesn't kill you makes you
stronger then we date anybody you sing
with you end up dating did you know that
well does Val know about us there's
something going on here isn't
there the guy yeah what does that make
you know you're the one witnessing all
of this well I I'm a fundamentalist
Christian and I need a Chapo and I kiss
Dating Goodbye if you get that reference
that's a weird one I was going to ask
what something in your house that you're
particularly proud of meaning I'm giving
you a green light to tell me about a a a
a loadbearing beam that has yeah I
thought I was literally coming here just
to give you some construction advice
no I'm are we starting now are we
starting the podcast where podcast
starts now okay okay aren't you glad
that I didn't say what would you do with
this studio [__] that [__] way first of
all can I just I'm gon to I'm G to Pat
your ego for a moment here I'll get it
ready you are an
incredible conversationalist oh you are
too man and your your talk show I
thought was so incredible that's from
the background yeah the podcast is so
incredible because it's not I I hate
going on to a show and I've said this
for years like no one tunes into to me
if I'm doing a segment because they want
to learn the next trending paint colors
right they want to laugh they want to
hear something from the heart they want
to so anyway just so you know this has
been a total Joy I really appreciate but
um in my house yeah my favorite room is
the salarium so I we built out we
basically did a small Edition the back
so we could encl so it's like a sun room
yeah exactly so it's the most naturally
light filled room literally like a
kettletop glass roof that you I totally
just threw up a little bit yeah I
totally burped in the mic side I'm
really rude remember we said I'm Not The
Classy classic one no I love it um I'm
more like Canadian tuxedo yes which is
very trendy right now because uh Brad
Pit wore one in uh Once Upon I
everything he knows I wrote down I need
a Brad Pit story from you come on D he
was great anyway salarium so that's
where we hosted our dinner the other
night and and uh it's just so beautiful
it's all we have all the trees olive
trees in there and a green wall and it's
what's a green wall like it like a plant
wall good for the air right yeah it's
beautiful and you know like we we grow a
lot of our own vegetables and everything
as well we have the lettuce grow Farm
stands and stuff like that um Zoe
actually started that company with her
ex-husband and um we're all very close
and it's nice to be able to be
surrounded by Nature where we live is so
quiet and private and you literally have
this magical moment in that room you sit
there and if you're reading or writing
or whatever you're doing it's just
incredible so this
really you you it's it's kind of slid by
but you were like you don't watch TV and
I'm just so glad that you're not because
you could be sitting in the salarium
yeah i' have I'd have to install a TV in
the salarium and that's just which would
ruin aot of work now it's blue light
it's un natural but anyway no that's uh
so you made a salarium is there's
Furniture in it I'm really trying to
picture it um well it's uh I'll show you
pictures after but we have um usually I
so I Custom Design two sofas Big sofas
for in there they're super cozy and
loungy and it's just that with a coffee
table nice um when we're doing an event
we do long Harvest tables across the
whole room um between the trees and then
we'll set it up and our happy number in
there is 24 we can have 24 guests for
dinner I love that you know that we've
you should have a sign that says
occupancy over 24 is not socially viable
exactly like it's not a fire hazard no
pants no shoes and no one over 24 people
allowed in this space but we set up the
whole I mean I literally designed it to
solve all of our problems as the kids
get older and they're six and eight
right now and what their needs will be
and you know do we want to have people
come visit we've got the guest house and
um even in the yard you know when we
throw big Halloween parties or whatever
it might be I've set it up so there's
infrastructure around the entire yard to
plug in bouncy castles to do this to
that anything I could possibly think of
so that we can host and and have friends
around it's set up so it really makes
everything easier for us because you
know you have your zones everything's
all zoned isn't it funny I look I don't
mean to belabor this but I have to
imagine you like what you do so if this
gets old you let me know but it's
interesting how like little things like
Outlet placement an old old hotel
where's the outlet it's behind the bed
you have to move the bed and now there's
USBC there's and and I'm just like that
Human animals aren't that complicated
they just want to be like did you think
of me and it actually goes back to what
you're saying about this podcast it's
like can we actually just create a space
wherein we witness one another and like
create something together you know what
I mean and and say I see you yeah and a
and a space can say I see you so Drew
and My Philosophy is that your home
should make your life easier period yeah
that's all it is well do you have you
know half your life spent doing laundry
for the kids and and all right maybe
there's something there you can do that
makes that easier or faster yeah um is
it do you work from home and you need
Flex space there are so many solutions
every family is different you know we
what I love is we're actually
relaunching our website to be more of
like an online magazine because we had a
print magazine for a while and print
it's just a very challenging realm but
people want the assistance they want the
help our sole goal with Drew and
jonathan.com is to get people enough
information so they can make life easier
love their more you shouldn't you know
feel you're spending all your time
struggling with the house and then you
have no time to enjoy with the family so
that's our entire philosophy is how can
we help people make their home make life
easier this has been great I've really
enjoyed oh tell me a Brad Pit thing
that's what we were going to do oh he
would you mind so the funny thing is so
Brad did celebrity IOU which we just
finished our 55th episode of that show
it's incredible every time we cast a new
season I'm like I I don't know how I
fell into such a a great you know you
just touched on it it's it's it's so of
use and that doesn't mean people are
using you but people are excited for
useful people yeah you know what I mean
well and and you sometimes you want to
say thank you so for anyone who doesn't
know celebrity I you basically we
partner with big celebrities and they
give back to someone who's been
instrumental in their life in making
them the success that they are um Hal
Barry gave back to her fourth grade
teacher um you know Melissa McCarthy
gave back to her uncle who was a poli
policeman who actually got injured in
the field uh and um you know had trouble
Mobility trouble at home and all
everyone's got a different story Brad
Pit it was his makeup artist who had
been with him for 35 years through thick
and thin and really he said like he
would literally just go to her house and
crash on her sofa sometimes when he just
needed a break he needed to get away W
and um that must have been hard on
her yeah she's actually around yeah uh
the funny thing too is the number one
question I got after we did the Brad Pit
episode was did he smell nice yeah
mahogany and courage I mean I don't
remember exactly what he smelled like
but I'm sure it was fine what I remember
is somebody is in charge of his smell he
is you know what there aren't all people
think there are all these people around
him the dude is so down to earth yeah I
actually didn't think he was that sort
of way and I'm going to take back my rib
it was a joke there are some people yeah
but but there are some people
that just have it yeah I know that's so
stupid no it's true he just I'm like
this guy's but you know what really made
a a mark on me is um he so throughout
the renovation he came back several
times to work with us and you know get
all these different jobs done that we
wanted to do and he remembered every
single person's name on the crew and in
the construction crew so the camera crew
and the construction crew and when he
came back for the reveal yeah that's
this is Marty Marty Marty's coming up to
you now on the left um oh he was just so
so so chill about it and everything and
you know cuz we sometimes you work with
people that we' we've implemented a no
douchebag rule we're not no longer going
to work with people who are in it
for publicity or in it for something
else we want genuinely right it can't be
toot the movie no exactly and so cuz I
found that the people who are not
genuinely into being on Celebrity IOU
they're like rushing to get out or oh
and it's like they're they're
accommodating Us by making time I'm like
this is really supposed to be a
beautiful thing giving back to someone
who's so important in your life yeah and
there's these people have wanted to do
this for a long time and what better way
than something that's actually going to
transform their lives and some of the
stories I remember Michael bé it was his
grandfather that got him into music sat
him down at the record player put on
kuner tunes and got him into music even
negotiated with a local bar to allow him
as a child to go in and sing uh and
perform his very first public
performance like you do have to have two
martinis yeah exactly it's two two come
in but you have to have two martinis um
but you know so then his grandfather
when he was older and his health was
ailing um Michael actually was giving
back to the nurse who was with his
grandfather for the last 10 years of his
life Wow who when the grandfather passed
away the nurse didn't really have a home
to raise her child safely so Michael
renovated and gifted this to her so all
everyone has a story and we realized
it's the excitement of having the
celebrity but it's the the gift and the
benefit is going to somebody who really
needs it and there needs to be it has to
be genuine yeah and and heartfelt which
is why we haven't had you on the show
well I've been sitting here going like
God I got to do a movie or
something so so I can get in there how
do I get this uh no it's just for me no
I okay I'm not going to lie so we I'm
going to tell you something this is
really it's not [__] but it's a little
[__] we a lot of celebrities will
reach out and they just want something
for themselves we had one celebrity that
reached out and they wanted to gift it
to their wife I'm like but wait you guys
both live in the same house he's like
yeah yeah no but you know like she like
she could really use this that's like
when the mafia like when Tony Soprano
would give Carmela yeah
$999,000 because $100,000 was too yeah
to avoid
taxes but also uh we we've had
celebrities who reach out and they want
us to have them on ciou but they're a
gift back to their investment property
and I'm like I really don't think you're
understanding the purpose of the show
yeah yeah so oh man but you know what
teach their own I I I I applaud the the
boldness the boldness the honesty of
asking um but no no that's not the case
so Brad knew everybody's uh names and he
was down to earth hyper
obsessed yeah he just ate with everybody
just yeah just you know there's certain
people he just makes me happy that he's
not like I'm doing South Beach or
whatever like he's just [__] I can't
even I could go through the list if we
had I don't have the list but like you
know Viola Davis Allison Janney like
they're all
so kind they're just they're down I
don't like pretentious people cell
phones I don't like people that have to
like have trouble like just being normal
yeah and uh so when we get to work with
these folks the new season as well is is
incredible I I don't know I can't say
yet who's in the new season but it's um
when it's announced it's like you'll
just see this eclectic mix of of
incredible people and uh it's a joy to
make and then and we and we still make
40 episodes of our shows a year Property
Brothers brother versus Brothers
celebrity IOU W um and then we produce
another 13 series with other talent in
addition to that so and you don't feel
overburdened Drew and I naturally divide
and conquer everything so it's been
pretty great on the product side I run
with all of that Drew runs with the
production we're at a point though where
I love that we only film in one place
and so we're only filming our shows in
La cuz I love taking the kids to school
in the morning and I love being home for
dinner every night yeah and that never
happened in the past Drew has a
16-month-old now and so priorities have
changed for Drew and Linda yeah so yeah
yeah Linda that sounds like a fake wife
and Drew's wife Linda if you don't want
to tell me his wife name I don't I just
don't trust you enough yet yeah yeah
yeah we'll we'll get the real name later
and how is it be becoming a dad I I
think I can I start with a compliment
yeah if I were to like lab design a guy
that could enter into a relationship and
the kids would be psyched it's you um
and it's not because of the White Horse
video I mean like you're real you seem
like you'd be really really fun with
kids and you do a cool thing like a like
a kids love playing
creating and you're someone who
maintained that spark let me tell you
why it's funny that you say this because
genetically you couldn't have created a
better bonus dad bonus
dad I used to be a clown I was a
professional clown for many years we
haven't even talked about magic I'm a
magician yes and I can build stuff yeah
what else no I know I mean that had to
be something that Zoey recognized I mean
that had talk about things changing you
go like it's not just like does he have
a motorcycle or whatever is he exciting
for me but you're going like oh this guy
just did closeup magic the kids are
going to I think it was the glutes for
Zoe your glutes the glutes I think
that's what sold Zoe
yeah what you clowning I was a clown
yeah I laughed at at the admission never
laugh at your GL um no we did so we when
we were kids so we grew up in a pretty
strict household it was we grew up in a
ran and so like we were we didn't get a
a allowance to do stuff you do it and so
like we shoveled horseshit and we're
painting fences and weeding and blah
blah blah but we uh when we turned eight
my dad legitimately told us we had to
get a job he wanted us to learn to work
for somebody else to do something else
and so we had the paper open and we're
looking at the
classifi um which nowadays nobody will
know what the hell that is but um and we
saw an ad from Parks and wreck and it
was um learn to be a clown they had a
workshop learn to juggle face paint do
magic and then they'll hire you for
parades and stuff afterward if it works
out so we're 8 years old dad was like
not what I was thinking not what I had
in mind Scottish accent and so he uh my
dad is the dad from uh head he Pon new
yeah yeah So I Married An I Married an
expert so that is my dad anyway so um we
went did this course learned this and
sure enough they started putting us out
for parades and as assistant like
assistant clowns and stuff cuz we're
still just kids it's funny cuz clowning
totally ruins the fact that you're twins
uh it does because we had different
characteristics um but maybe that was
what you liked about it it's like
finally I'm just
Jonathan Drew's been trying to make it
just Property Brother for a long time
he's been trying to kill me but it's not
going to happen no but anyway did that
and eventually we started our own
business at like 12 we were doing our
own birthday parties and stuff making
like 50 bucks an hour which was C
incredible like this is what so I'm 45
so it's like 30 years ago and uh anyway
so we um eventually I started doing more
magic instead of clowning because I
didn't like putting on all the makeup
and everything every time yeah and uh
did that for years one a bunch of awards
even performed like a big show in Vegas
and stuff like that do you know I love
magic no I didn't know yeah I like legit
love magic dude we just had a magic
dinner party at our house two weeks ago
who did you have um who came Jack
Jackson rid's the name of the magician I
if you ever met incredibly talented we
had a tarot card reader as well and I'm
telling you everyone so we invited
everyone who we know is who appreciates
magic who are not magicians yeah we
wanted really experience and it was the
most incredible evening everyone left
and their minds were blown I even
performed as well I did a a card
selection where I I I find the card with
a nail gun everyone knows instruction
you shoot the deck and it's only I I had
somebody hold
uh a board and then I throw the cards
and I shoot threw it at the board and of
course they're sweating andever but it's
a good time so we I I still that's real
magic that's like a real thing oh yeah I
love I I'm obsessed I love magic I'm a
member of the castle and I did a
renovation at the castle too for them I
I added uh space there at the castle I'm
forgetting his name Katie would you
Google you made a weird magician just
Justin Wilman it's not Wilman sorry
Justin I Justin's incredible and
hilarious it's it's Taylor or Tyler or
[__] I'm embarrassed I'm forgetting his
name but he has a trick that I literally
spend nights still laying up and trying
to think about I do magic as well a as a
as a appreciator like I like knowing how
things are done not to ruin it and I I
don't go blabbing but I like the
mechanics of it I like the the art of it
and his trick I'm going to we're going
to try and get his
name come on I bet I have him in my
phone as
magician let's see what do you have me
in your phone as magician all right no
[__] I'm sorry buddy the trick is okay
can you go on YouTube and type in um
lottery ticket
trick um the trick is I'm going to tell
you everything okay and you're going to
love it okay maybe we should just watch
it but he gets uh five there's five six
people around and I know you what you're
thinking as a magician you're like what
happened before the cameras start
rolling but like I'm like it can't be
that you know what I mean like there's
certain tricks where it's like maybe
they pulled them on the phone yeah like
if I see a trick and I want to figure it
out I I like to be there in person to
witness it yeah so we weren't there
before it happened but I don't see any
way in there Nate Nate what's his name s
Nate Santa forth yeah Nate okay so Nate
Santa forth okay he gets five people
I've also seen him do it in a crowd to
call out numers
and then he takes out a lottery ticket
in his pocket and it's those numbers and
that is the best [__] trick and I've
also so I've asked him a lot of
questions about it he like let he lets
me ask him one question about it per
year and one of them was you know I like
to ask things
like uh is it really random and he goes
like yeah and I wanted to prove that one
time because I would I one time he did
the trick by standing with his back to
the audience and throw the a ball and if
you caught it you said one of the
numbers I know as I'm saying it it
sounds boring to me but if you see
someone five random people name five
numbers then he takes out his wallet
which was on him the whole time yeah and
I've I you know obviously and I'm not
trying to take anything away I'm like
how can we do this like literally you'd
have to build something like the
mechanics of it so what I think is great
so I used to design a lot of the
illusions that I perform and I I
intentionally designed Illusions to fool
other magicians and pisses them off they
[__] hated it generally there are
only so many principles in Magic and
everything you see is a different color
painted prop or a different pres that's
why I like is it's some sort of force
you get them to say the numbers you want
and again it could be any number of ways
I appreciate the Artistry that goes into
creating a routine because if someone
was to figure out how a routine worked
normally the reaction would be like oh
it's always disappointing that's it but
to actually come up with that and all of
the safeguards to to prevent someone
from fig it is so complicated and it's
so incredibly you need talent in order
to do that oh yeah um that's why I so I
can go in and most of the time I'll know
how all even with a mentalist trick like
that I used to do a lot of mentalism
yeah and I I loved uh mentalism and so
there because I saw a guy at the castle
same thing bartender everybody shouted
out a card and he turned the cards over
and it was the cards that everyone had
said and you're just like that's just
well he's the chances are he's probably
a demon yeah a demon or an evil wizard
yeah uh but no it's something like I can
appreciate it and even if I can't figure
it out it doesn't it doesn't eat me out
eat me out it does eat me out but it yes
rim job uh it doesn't eat me up inside
because um you can't ultimately figure
out everything because there are so many
different methods to accomplish
something even if you think you know the
one method it might not be the method
and there's others I remember like
copper field as well he used to have
multiple ways that he could perform
certain effects so that even if somebody
thought they figured one way out he
could actually do it another way so
there's a lot that goes into do you have
stories like that let me let me Prime
you with this I used to do uh David
Blain's name a number between one and 50
yeah odd numbers and sometimes they'd
say you mean like this and you go yeah
and you'd have to adapt those are my
favorite magic stories is where like
something goes wrong yeah and you have
to like has that happened to you you'll
get people sometimes who will
potentially try and throw you off or
ruin it was funny cuz um not not in
necessarily in a malicious way but I was
working with um I don't know if I'm
allowed to say I don't know if it's been
announced for ciou who this celebrity
was but huge celebrity she's incredibly
talented and award-winning anyway so
turns out in in the scene I'm doing with
her I'm just performing a really simple
kids trick like a Vanishing coin kind of
a thing and she aggressively grabs my
arm and says I know it's in this other
hand and I was was like was was it Sarah
Silverman no no because one time my
friend who's also a magician was doing
magic for Sarah and she was I was deeply
embarrassed that she kept going like oh
so you can make me uh take that like she
was she was being funny but I was like
stop it yeah no this was it was she was
still being sweet about and she thought
it was and it was funny in the scene
that we were doing but there's some
people who I remember magicians always
they did a lot of magicians didn't want
to perform on Letterman because
Letterman would famously ruin it yeah
and so it's for me I would never ruin
someone's effect um but I I can
appreciate when somebody is really
really skilled and when somebody's doing
something like that's why the kids
always want me to teach them magic
tricks this is why kids are the worst
because you show them something and then
they and they immediately go and perform
it for somebody badly yeah and then
right after they finish you want me to
tell you how it it's done yeah and like
so like no this is me and Leela you got
to learn we've been doing fake thumb
stuff which can be some of the fake
thumb magic is actually oh yeah I think
I convinced everybody I worked with that
I was a demon because I would make
cigarettes disappear lit cigarettes yeah
and because I walked around with a fake
thumb because I'm a dork but I also
looked like a [__] wizard yeah it was
the best do the fake fake pinky for her
you just take the the pinky and you just
push it into your
hand yes yes right in there yes oh see
everyone does thumb you do pinky I do
pinky that's very good yeah Leela I hope
she's into magic because it teaches you
how to follow a recipe I don't mean so
she can cook it just helps your brain no
it's magic is great and it's also it's
it's an interesting thing I think when
kids start to and I remember myself I
learned from the Tarbell book of magic
there was no internet when I was
learning magic it was all me too I got
books from the library yeah and it's
very hard to learn visual art fig words
yeah exactly now you can just go online
yeah but the so you would learn and you
would practice and practice and you
realize that the better you got the more
impressive the reactions were and it's I
think it's a fun healthy thing yeah um
but also to get interested in trains you
to slow your heart rate like The Witcher
like you have to like nothing Jacks your
adrenaline my adrenaline I go on stage
I'm pretty I'm very calm I feel very
comfortable my heart rate definitely
goes up but I like going on St some
jacking your adal someone jacking my
adrenaline
I named my dick
adrenaline and uh but if you want me to
do a magic trick my hands will shake
yeah I can't I haven't yet learned
that's why it's so cool that David blae
is so like do you want me to like
because he he's so low well that's
that's his Persona as well is not having
like any emotion at all he's got to be
one of the most talented manipulators of
all time like his pressed digitation is
next Lev
do the um what is it
called the pr I can't believe I'm
blanking on it I used to practice it all
the time it's called the double his
double lift is called the press off that
you just apply just enough pressure so
you're lifting two cards instead of one
but it's the most natural he flips it on
this part of his hand yeah you know what
I'm talking about yeah yeah because it's
[__] dope I think he I don't know if
he made it up double lift press off I
think is what it's called There's um
yeah I mean that's why you're supposed
to practice something so much even to
this day there certain routines that I
do that I've been doing since I was 8
years old yeah and it's natural like you
nobody even if they're a magician like
you can't tell and the problem is I'm so
busy in other aspects that I don't
really get to create there I have
illusions that I actually designed and
never performed um just because I got so
busy doing construction and Property
Brothers and 20,000 shows 20,000 shows
but um magic how do you do your double
up you go from the back I have a number
of different ways I'm not going to tell
you how I do all these things I got uh I
got multiple I got multitudes of
manipulations sure you do I'm very
impressed iteration on that I loved it
and I'm not going to acronym it the uh
but when somebody does a bad double lift
it's or triple LIF well my favorite
trick to do has a triple lift in it but
it also has a moment where you're it's a
David bla trick where you're holding a
card and if they do flip it over it is
what you said it is which is one of my
favorite it's like builtin the doubt
allowance is high so if they go really
and it is and then you're like [__] you
I it I love it always planning the
lowest common denominator yeah there's
there's a moment later in the trick
where if they did the same thing it
would ruin everything they've already
learned they've already learned to shut
the [__] up and just be delighted damn
it part of being a good magician is
making sure you can pick the right
participants that's brilliant I love
that yeah it's the same with hypnotists
like I did a little bit of hypnotism not
much because I actually met a guy whose
name was something Sterling and my mum
silver and we were like this could be
great we could do a show with magic and
me and hypnotism called sterling silver
uh never happened but he was teaching me
some stuff and I thought it was so
fascinating but one of the things is
when you're looking at your audience
everybody has the ability to be
hypnotized and it's almost like playing
along but just subconsciously you're
kind of like just okay with the
suggestions that they're giving and you
kind of do it but there are certain
people who if you do not want to be
hypnotized you cannot be hypnotized it
will not happen it will not work there's
a firewall yeah and so you have to be
good at who you're sussing out and same
with a magician there are some people
who you know magic is not Wizardry it's
the art of tricking people that's all it
is so you want to find a trickable
person yeah or or somebody who's just
okay playing along who's sort of sweet
and innocent and and they're okay
playing along because you're putting on
a show or they're already hypnotized
yeah like I always forget his name I
always have you look it up Darren Chris
oh um yeah you know who it is the guy
who has that smoo special he has the
Netflix special where he heals people
but it's not real yeah [__] I love him
he's a he's an ardan atheist anyway he
does a trick he opens a special it's a
wide shot he's in the Streets of London
and he just goes up to somebody they're
but it's key that they're like Darren
Brown Darren Brown the key is and this
isn't taking anything away from him but
to your point he's finding someone who's
walking to work so they're like doing
something by rot and they're already in
kind of a susceptible place and he gets
them to give him their cell phone and
their wallet just by saying like he asks
for directions and then he goes and
you'll give me your cell phone I can
have your cell phone and and can I have
your wallet too cuz and he gives both of
them and he walks away and it's
incredible and you know and you know
it's real it's [__]
insane yeah nobody's getting my wallet
or my cell phone yeah it's true it's
true well I've also been hypnotized I
went to a hypnotherapist for a long time
and I loved her I still love her um she
hypnotized you to love her I know she
was always planting but you remember
everything that happens you're just like
in a certain you allow yourself to enter
into a state but you know what would
happen when I would be hypnotized is my
arms would levitate and she said that
that was normal like because you're like
you're surrendering so much you almost
like lose track of your body and you're
just like what do I do with my hands
what do I do with my hands do you have
any thoughts on the meaning of life just
real quick before we go the meaning I
mean my whole thought is the meaning of
life is to is to live it and
I don't know what people are planning
for I'll live it in the future or
they're dwelling on oh I didn't live it
right in the past yeah guess what right
now live it right now yeah don't save up
your whole life to accidentally have
something happen and you never get to
enjoy anything yeah or I'll be happy
once I get to the beach be happy on the
plane yeah totally fine be happy on the
plane all that's why I feel like most
people take everything right now
everyone seems poised to fight about
everything I'm like I think we have a
lot more similarities than we think we
do but uh we sure could you know do well
with a conversation I'm okay I think it
was Larry King that said if I only ever
spoke to people with the same opinion as
me I'd never learn anything yeah it's
true let's just take it easy a little
Len up a little I I I completely agree
any feelings about God or the creation
or anything what's going on I I mean for
me you you talk to so many people who
have so many passionate opinions about
everything out there I have no problem
with how somebody wants to live their
life how they want to worship who they
want to worship as long as it's done in
a way that doesn't infringe on the
rights of others and uh you know for me
I love I mean I grew up Presbyterian and
you know I believe I don't necessarily
think people have to go into a building
to to show their faith um you know
people can pursue their religion and
their faith in different ways but I do
believe that you know that I I'd like to
believe that there's something more more
than what we are and what we're
experiencing right now who knows what
that is but yeah yeah yeah yeah you made
me think of the quote it's um anyone can
go to church the trick is to never leave
it sort of thing yeah I mean it's true
like you you find so many people that
get so obsessed about something that was
told to them by a human yeah in a
building yeah um and they maybe forget
what the overarching idea was of a
certain
practice and so that's why you know you
look at a lot of companies a lot of
corporations that have um basically
weaponized religion to try and convince
people to do some vote a certain way do
something a certain way I'm like I don't
trust those people and so I hate you
know we I did a lot of fighting when it
comes to renewable energy and getting
people to understand what's actually
happening in in energy and it's pretty
scary I did a documentary on PBS and it
won a bunch of awards uh but it was um
called Jonathan Scott's Power Trip and
uh the thing that I discovered is it's
so blatant these days that these
disinformation campaigns and it's so
unhealthy it does not help people it
hurts people and um these companies just
keep getting richer by doing it and so
for me that's the real problem I have it
uh when it comes to religion is that
these outside influences have realized
they can use people's faith right
to Coop go go after their agenda so I
don't like that yeah I like I I like
your style like your moves foot touch to
finish it now who's who's bigger um
you're bigger you're wearing like those
flared out bottom shoes no this is
because you have to take it off and then
with a zip here we go now take it off
are you 13 14 13 oh we're exactly the
same oh that's sweet sorry bro oh man
not sorry bro but we could the sweetest
end to any
podcast this was a real pleasure my
friend dude thank you would you say keep
it crispy it's how we end keep it crispy
he just did it oh and these are for you
the first person you have similar hair
to me modern mammals get it magic mine I
thought you were giving me your shoe no
not my shoes those are for you thank you
so much yeah all right peace out thanks
everybody you made it you made it you
made it oh yeah you made it with you
made it with you made it with oh yeah
you made it with you made it with you
made it with all yeah you made it with
you made it you made it with
all